couvrir le sol ça apporte toutes sortes
davantage ça permet de lutter contre
l'érosion d'améliorer la fertilité la
structure du sol et ça peut se faire en
bio comment conventionnel un grande
comme à toute petite échelle
[Musique]
chacune de ces petites semences
deviendra une plante de couverture qui
nourrira le sol à sa façon
plus on va mettre des racines plus on va
structurer le sol plus on empile les
couches de carbone qui deviennent
l'humus plus on est résilient la
sécheresse et lorsque la plante et ses
racines vont se décomposer une foule
d'éléments nutritifs seront alors
disponibles dans le sol car jean
magazine dans un tissu d'une plante
exemples comme ceux sarrazin le
j'emmagasine des éléments nutritifs de
d'un ils peuvent pas partir aux ovins
comme le phosphore par dans les cours
d'eau ou pas réparé au érosion éolienne
ils peuvent pas partir ou 20 ils peuvent
pas se perdre ils sont transformés en
humus cette mesure va se minéraliser le
moment venu couvrir les sols en
permanence permet donc d'éviter ceux ci
le mois de mai c'est le mois des semis
mais c'est aussi celui des panaches de
poussière quand on sème dans un sol à nu
c'est le spectacle qui s'offre à nous ce
que le vent transporte ici c'est de la
précieuse terres arables et ce sont
aussi des résidus d'engrais et de
pesticides
et voyez ce qui arrive quand on sème
dans du vivant pas une seule particules
de sol ne s'envolent ici un champ de
seigle reçoit un semis de soya plus
lourd ce soir a été adapté pour pouvoir
planter les graines directement à
travers la couverture vivante mais ce
qui sera vendu au final c'est le soya il
faut alors éviter que le seigle ne
vienne lui faire de l'ombre et pompé
tout son nous
maintenant que cette culture de
couverture a rempli sa mission de
nourrir le sol il est temps de la
détruire
on sort donc le glyphosate pour se
débarrasser du couvert et laisser la
voie libre à la culture principale
agro écologie ne signifie pas
agriculture biologique les pesticides ne
sont donc pas strictement interdite
l'agroécologie son maillon faible c'est
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires donc les herbicides plus
particulièrement pour débarrasser le
couvert comme ça ça prend du glyphosate
on a développé des techniques où on
utilise un peu moins de glyphosate mais
on en utilise encore
l'agroécologie insiste beaucoup sur la
transition vers des systèmes agricoles
ou des systèmes alimentaires durables
donc dans cette perspective là utilisé
du pli fô that ce n'est pas
agroécologiques mais on peut comprendre
qu'un agriculteur dans une transition
vers une agriculture durable va
peut-être l'utiliser pendant un certain
temps mais avec l'objectif quand même de
pouvoir s'en passer plus ou moins brève
échéance